Puerto Rico, la isla de Ricky Martin, Bad
Bunny, Daddy Yankee y las piñas coladas también
es conocida por su particular estatus político:
esta isla no es un estado, sino un estado
libre asociado de los Estados Unidos de América.
Un estatus tan particular como controvertido,
porque Puerto Rico pese a estar bajo soberanía
norteamericana no vota por el presidente,
ni tampoco por senadores ni congresistas con
derecho a voto.
Pese a ello, los puertorriqueños han ratificado
una y otra vez su deseo de permanecer dentro
de este esquema. Sin embargo, desde hace algunos
años algo está cambiando.
La pregunta, ¿están listos los puertorriqueños
para dar un siguiente paso? ¿Hacía dónde
se dirige la también conocida como isla del
encanto?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os
vamos a contar todos los detalles.
Arranquemos.
Puerto Rico se ha convertido en la mayor economía
del caribe y sus estándares de vida son relativamente
altos. Evidentemente formar parte del gigante
norteamericano tiene algunos beneficios.
Y quizás por eso tanto el gobierno como los
propios isleños nunca se han lanzado a ninguna
aventura independentista. Siempre han estado
muy apegados a su régimen de Estado Libre
Asociado.
Sin embargo, los últimos años no han sido
fáciles y el modelo parece cada vez más
agotado y no termina de convencer a prácticamente
nadie: los puertorriqueños son ciudadanos
estadounidenses, sí, pero no tienen representación
real en el Congreso, no votan a las autoridades
federales y su justicia no es del todo autónoma.
En cierto modo Puerto Rico sigue siendo una
colonia.
Quizás por eso, los propios puertorriqueños
han dicho BASTA, es tiempo de avanzar… Eso
sí, no para alejarse de Estados Unidos sino
para integrarse por completo en el gigante
norteamericano.
La pregunta es, ¿es esto realmente posible?
¿Veremos pronto a Puerto Rico convertido
en el estado número 51 de la unión? ¿Qué
podría suponer ese cambio para la isla?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os
vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes, antes tenemos que ver un poco de historia
para saber dónde comenzó todo.
Vamos con ello.
[Pero antes dejadme que os haga una pregunta:
todos hemos visto gráficos como este:
Tras un año terriblemente loco, el precio
del gas ha vuelto a niveles previos a la guerra
de Ucrania. La crisis energética que amenazó
con dejarnos sin blanca y provocar un montón
de apagones parece haber quedado atrás y
el armageddon energético se ha evitado.
Pero, ¿realmente la crisis ya se ha terminado?
Y si os dijera que es muy probable que veamos
todavía precios del gas por las nubes en
los próximos meses? No os perdáis el último
de Alberto en Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal
de información financiera de Mutuactivos
con el que participamos. Os ayudará a comprender
mejor que demonios está ocurriendo con el
tema del gas y qué podemos esperar.]
Dicho esto, ahora sí, volvamos a Puerto Rico.
(T1: DE MADRID A FORAKER Y JONES)
Durante su segunda travesía al continente
americano, Cristóbal Colón se topó con
la isla que hoy todos conocemos como Puerto
Rico.
Su capital, San Juan, fue así nombrada en
honor al príncipe Juan, por aquel entonces
Príncipe de Asturias y heredero al trono
de Castilla y Aragón.
Desde ese momento y durante más de 400 años
la corona española mantuvo el control de
la isla hasta que finalmente en el s.XIX un
enfrentamiento entre España y Estados Unidos
cambió esta relación.
(En 1895 estalló la guerra de Cuba. En este
conflicto revolucionarios sublevados independentistas
se enfrentaron a los realistas españoles.
La presión para la Corona era cada vez mayor
y su posición más comprometida. Para intentar
aliviar la situación y el cada vez más fuerte
sentimiento independentista en 1897 Madrid
reconoció como autonomías tanto a Cuba como
a Puerto Rico.
Sin embargo, no fue suficiente y, además,
la ayuda del Tio Sam terminó estando a favor
de los sublevados. Finalmente un choque político-militar
entre España y Estados Unidos en 1898 terminó
con la estrepitosa derrota del viejo imperio.
El acuerdo de paz alcanzado estableció que
Cuba quedaba bajo la tutela norteamericana
mientras que Puerto Rico, Guam y Filipinas
pasaron a ser directamente dependencias coloniales
de Estados Unidos)
Por primera vez Estados Unidos demostró no
sólo su fuerza, sino sobre todo su estatus
de potencia y su capacidad de intervenir en
el exterior para limitar la influencia europea
en la región.
Sin embargo, pese a ello no estaba del todo
claro cuál sería su relación con estos
nuevos territorios que ahora tenía bajo su
control.
Digamos que en Washington no querían emular
el viejo esquema colonial del Imperio español
o el Imperio británico. [Lo que tiene sentido.
Al fin y al cabo ellos este país nació luchando
contra el propio concepto de colonia.]
Fue entonces, cuando en el año 1900, el entonces
senador de Ohio, Joseph B. Foraker, lideró
la redacción y aprobación de una ley bautizada
con su propio apellido, la Ley Foraker; una
ley que estableció el nuevo esquema político
que se aplicaría desde ese momento en Puerto
Rico.
Por ejemplo, esta ley determinó que el propio
Presidente de los Estados Unidos nombraría
por 4 años a un gobernador, el cual debería
gobernar junto a un Consejo Ejecutivo en el
que como mínimo de sus 11 miembros, 5 tendrían
que ser puertorriqueños.
(De forma simultánea comenzó a funcionar
en la isla una pequeña Cámara de Delegados
locales formada por 35 miembros escogidos
por la población local. Por su parte, para
gestionar el sistema judicial de la isla se
creó la Corte de Distrito de los Estados
Unidos para Puerto Rico y se estableció el
recurso de apelación ante la Corte Suprema
de Estados Unidos.
Asimismo, y pese a no ser un estado, los puertorriqueños
tendrían la posibilidad de elegir un “Comisionado
Residente”, el cual tendría voz pero no
voto en la Cámara de Representantes de los
EE. UU.)
La apuesta se redoblaría apenas 17 años
más tarde. En 1917, la Jones-Shafroth, rubricada
por el entonces presidente Woodrow Wilson
dio un golpe en la mesa con su artículo 5.
¿Y qué decía este artículo? Pues… Fijaos.
C0 (“Todos los ciudadanos de Puerto Rico
[...] y todos los nativos de Puerto Rico que
estaban temporalmente ausentes de la Isla
el 11 de abril de 1899, y hayan regresado
después y estén residiendo permanentemente
en dicha isla, y no sean ciudadanos de ningún
país extranjero, se declaran por la presente
ciudadanos de los Estados Unidos, y serán
considerados y tenidos como tales. Ley Jones-Shafroth
(1917))
De golpe y porrazo, se hizo algo muy poco
habitual en aquella época: reconocer como
ciudadanos de Estados Unidos a los puertorriqueños.
Un privilegio sin precedentes: no nacían
en un estado formal de los Estados Unidos,
pero pese a ello gozaban de los mismos derechos.
[Por cierto, ¿os habéis fijado en qué año
se aprobó esta ley? Se dice se cuenta que
esta iniciativa tuvo mucho que ver con incrementar
la base de reclutamiento en medio de la Primera
Guerra Mundial. Claro que no podemos saber
si ese fue el argumento clave.]
Sea como sea, La ley Jones-Shafroth también
generó una legislatura bicameral electa de
manera local y mucho más representativa,
una cámara que pasó a ser competente para
legislar sobre los asuntos de la isla.
Eso sí, tanto el gobernador de la isla como
incluso, llegado el caso, el Presidente de
Estados Unidos tenían derecho de veto.
El caso es que de esta forma, en tan solo
17 años, los puertorriqueños accedieron
a la ciudadanía norteamericana y plantaron
el prototipo de su gobierno civil. Pero…
¿Qué es exactamente esta isla? ¿Una colonia?
¿Un territorio subordinado a Estados Unidos?
Sí, los puertorriqueños son ciudadanos estadounidenses,
pero la relación de su tierra con el resto
del país es bastante diferente.
Atentos.
(T2 : COMMONW… AH NO, ESTADO LIBRE ASOCIADO)
El gobierno de Puerto Rico continuó siendo
elegido desde el despacho Oval, hasta 1947,
cuando la Ley 447 del Congreso de los Estados
Unidos estableció la posibilidad de que el
Gobernador isleño por fin fuese electo por
la población.
Fue así como Luis Muñoz Marín se convirtió
en el primer gobernador electo por los puertorriqueños.
Su gobierno duró nada más y nada menos que
16 años, y fue absolutamente clave para el
estatus de la isla.
En 1950, por ejemplo, Muñoz Marín logró
acordar con Washington la aprobación de la
Ley 600, que le dió a Puerto Rico la posibilidad
de tener su propia “constitución estatal”,
tal y como ya tenían el resto de los Estados
de la Unión. Una especie de ley fundamental
que fija la organización del territorio.
Pues bien, en este texto, que finalmente entró
en vigor en 1952, establece que Puerto Rico
es en sí mismo una «Commonwealth» adherida
a Estados Unidos, pero al estar el texto escrito
también en español, la traducción habla
de “Estado Libre Asociado” (ELA),
que es el estatus que aún mantiene la isla
actualmente..
Esto, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, supuso
un antes y un después. A partir de ese momento
la idea del propio Muñoz Marín es que Puerto
Rico tuviera cada vez más autonomía. Esta
que vais a ver es esencialmente la idea que
funda el Puerto Rico moderno y que define
su particular relación con Estados Unidos.
Fijaos.
(“Siempre habrá un área de autoridad que
delegaremos que será la defensa, la legislación
inherente a la común ciudadanía, la legislación
inherente a la moneda común y algunas otras
cosas por el estilo. Pero el progreso es que
cada día, según crezca el estado libre asociado,
los votos que ustedes y todos los puertorriqueños
emitimos en las urnas tengan mayor autoridad
sobre nuestras vidas”.)
Eso sí, no todo fue tan armónico.
En 1950 tuvo lugar el Grito de Jayuya, una
revuelta liderada por sectores independentistas
armados que, eso sí, rápidamente fue sofocada
por las fuerzas de seguridad. Digamos que
todo esto del estado libre asociado no les
acaba de encajar.
Sea como sea, en 1952, el presidente Dwight
Eisenhower dio el visto bueno pero exigió
que se celebrara un plebiscito para conocer
la verdadera voluntad de los puertorriqueños.
Los comicios se celebraron el 4 de noviembre
de aquel mismo año. Y, ¿Queréis saber el
resultado? Pues.. Ni más ni menos que el
87,8% de los isleños votaron a favor del
nuevo marco constitucional que establecía
el estado libre asociado. El apoyo fue como
veis aplastante, absolutamente mayoritario.
Este sería uno de los tantos referéndums
donde los puertorriqueños se han manifestado
a favor de mantener vinculación con Washington:
Digamos que casi podríamos decir que la segunda
mitad del siglo XX fue una especie luna de
miel entre los Estados Unidos continentales
y Puerto Rico.
Fijaos.
(T3 : SANCHEZ VALLE, EL TRAFICANTE DE ARMAS
QUE CAMBIÓ LA HISTORIA)
La segunda mitad del siglo XX fue una camino
lleno de flores para la economía puertorriqueña.
En 1950 el gobierno federal aprobó incentivos
fiscales para las empresas norteamericanas
que se establecieran en la isla, lo que generó
un espectacular boom económico
El gobierno federal estadounidense instauró
hacia 1950 un paquete de incentivos fiscales
para empresas americanas que se radicarán
en la isla, generando un enorme boom económico.
Fijaos la diferencia con el resto de América
Latina.
Construcciones, hoteles, negocios, nuevas
autopistas… la economía de Puerto Rico
comenzó a florecer. Y por supuesto esto tuvo
importantes implicaciones sociales: la pobreza
se redujo y prácticamente todos los parámetros
mejoraron. Durante años Puerto Rico fue considerado
todo un éxito.
Y ojo, porque desde que se celebrara en 1952
el primer referéndum, los puertorriqueños
han sido convocados a las urnas en 6 ocasiones
para manifestarse acerca del estatus de soberanía
de la isla. Lo hicieron en 1967, 1993, 1998,
2012, 2017 y 2020. En todos ellos ganó la
vinculación con Washington… Pero de formas
diferentes.
Si hasta 2012 ganaba el estado libre asociado,
a partir de ese año, la opción a favor de
convertirse en un estado más, un estado formal
de los Estados Unidos pasó a ser claramente
mayoritaria.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué provocó semejante
salto? ¿Por qué los puertorriqueños dejaron
de estar conformes con su actual estatus?
Pues bien, para responder a esa pregunta tenemos
que remontarnos hasta septiembre de 2008,
cuando Luis Sánchez del Valle fue capturado
en la isla por tráfico ilegal de armas. Fue
acusado simultáneamente por dicho cargo,
tanto por la justicia norteamericana como
por la justicia puertorriqueña.
Entonces, el acusado demandó al Estado de
la isla al considerar que una persona no podía
ser acusada dos veces por el mismo delito
en una misma jurisdicción, enmarcando así
el reconocido caso Puerto Rico v. Sánchez
Valle, que fue resuelto en 2015 con un polémico
fallo:
C1(“La autoridad de Puerto Rico para enjuiciar
personas se deriva de la delegación que efectuó
el Congreso de los Estados Unidos y no en
virtud de una soberanía propia (...) La adopción
de una constitución, por delegación del
Congreso, para organizar el gobierno local
en sustitución de gran parte de la ley orgánica
vigente entonces, no representó una cesión
de soberanía a Puerto Rico. Por el contrario,
Puerto Rico no dejó de ser un territorio
de los Estados Unidos.” Doctrina del Tribunal
Supremo de Puerto Rico)
Y os preguntaréis, ¿qué tiene esto de polémico?
Pues básicamente que los tribunales dejaron
claro que la soberanía de Puerto Rico no
recae en los puertorriqueños sino que sigue
estando en manos de Washington.
Con el paso de los años, esta concepción,
junto a problemas económicos que ya os hemos
contado en pasados vídeos hizo que de repente
se disparará la ambición de querer cambiar
el estatus de Puerto Rico.
En 2017, por ejemplo, Puerto Rico se encontraba
prácticamente en quiebra con una deuda externa
superior a los 70.000 millones de dólares.
De hecho no fue hasta enero de 2022 cuando
una junta de supervisión financiera designada
por el gobierno federal logró reestructurar
la deuda con los acreedores. Pero, por supuesto,
todavía queda mucho por delante hasta que
el problema se pueda dar por superado.
Pero, ¿Sabéis qué es lo más curioso de
todo? Lo curioso es que muchos de los problemas
económicos de Puerto Rico, sino la inmensa
mayoría, no tienen nada que ver con ser o
no un Estado Libre Asociado.
Hablamos de cosas como la ley Jones de la
marina mercantil aprobada en 1920 y que aún
hoy está en vigor. Una ley prohíbe que barcos
con bandera extranjera puedan transportar
mercancías entre dos puertos de los Estados
Unidos. Esto hace que trasladar cosas a y
desde Puerto Rico sea carísimo… lo que
evidentemente erosiona un montón la competitividad
de la isla. ¿Por qué? Pues porque los barcos
con bandera y tripulación de Estados Unidos
son muchísimo más caros de operar. Además,
esta ley hace que los grandes cargueros internacionales
no se puedan detener en Puerto Rico.
Hablamos también del salario mínimo y los
planes de subsidios federales. Pero para entender
esto, fijaos en este gráfico.
Como podéis ver, Puerto Rico es muuuucho
más pobre que el resto de Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, como tiene que aplicar el mismo
salario mínimo federal o un nivel anormalmente
alto de prestaciones sociales para lo que
son los parámetros de la isla.
Y aquí el problema es evidente. Lo que es
asumible para Texas no tiene porque serlo
de la misma forma para Puerto Rico. Las políticas
y regulaciones federales hacen que a la hora
de la verdad muy poca gente trabaje en Puerto
Rico.
Aunque, eso sí, las cosas están mejorando
gracias a nuevos incentivos fiscales para
las empresas que se instalan en la isla.
Pues bien, el caso es que ninguno de estos
problemas cambiaría si Puerto Rico deja de
ser un Estado Libre Asociado y se convierte
en un estado más. Incluso, algunos de sus
beneficios fiscales para las empresas y los
inversores podrían desaparecer por completo.
Sí, ganaría más integración, influencia
y probablemente inversiones del gobierno…
Pero por el camino se dejaría otras muchas
cosas.
Sea como sea esta opción, la de convertirse
en un estado más es la gran preferida por
los puertorriqueños. Fijaos.
(T4 : EL ESTATUS QUE PASÓ DE MODA)
En 2020, Puerto Rico realizó un nuevo referéndum,
pero esta vez ya ni el Estado Libre Asociado
ni la independencia eran una opción. La pregunta
era mucho más clara: “¿Debe Puerto Rico
ser admitido inmediatamente dentro de la Unión
como un Estado?”
Esta es exactamente la pregunta que se hizo
en aquella consulta. El sí obtuvo más del
50% de los votos, lo que le dio al gobierno
de la isla fuerza para hacer presión en Washington.
Una campaña que lidera en la que el actual
gobernador Pedro Pierluisi está volcado pero
que requiere superar un complicadísimo circuito
legislativo.
Por ejemplo, la Cámara de Representantes,
tiene que aprobar una ley que habilite la
realización de un referéndum vinculante
para el gobierno federal, es decir, una elección
que no solo sirva para que los ciudadanos
puedan manifestar su opinión - cómo las
ha sido hasta ahora -, sino que tenga consecuencias
jurídicas y políticas que permitan que el
presidente de Estados Unidos firme la incorporación
del nuevo estado.
En diciembre del 2022, con 233 votos a favor
y 191 en contra, sorprendentemente la Cámara
baja logró sancionar el Proyecto Cameral
8393. Se cumplió así el primer paso, pero
aún queda el Senado… Y eso, queridos amigos,
no es precisamente coser y cantar.
¿Por qué? Pues básicamente porque Puerto
Rico es un territorio políticamente muy demócrata.
Es decir, muchos republicanos tienen miedo
de que les vuelva a ocurrir lo que ya pasó
con Hawai, que Puerto Rico sea un feudo demócrata
que condicione la mayoría en las cámaras,
sobre todo claro está, en el nada proporcional
Senado, dónde todos los estados con independencia
de su tamaño tienen 2 representantes.
C2(“Tenemos que ir senador a senador, y
senadora por senadora, explicándoles por
qué es justo que se le dé la igualdad de
derechos a los ciudadanos americanos que residen
en Puerto Rico. También tenemos que explicarles
que Puerto Rico es diverso, que tampoco deben
pensar los senadores republicanos que si Puerto
Rico se convierte en un estado automáticamente
eso significa que habrá 2 senadores y 4 congresistas
demócratas”. Pedro Pierluisi, Gobernador
de Puerto Rico)
No sé, amigos, parece complicado. Pero quién
sabe.
En cualquier caso, el gobierno puertoriqueño
ha fijado ya el 5 de noviembre de 2023 como
la fecha para realizar un nuevo referéndum,
esperando que para entonces el Senado ya haya
dado luz verde y estos comicios puedan ser
el paso definitivo para convertirse en la
estrella 51 del pabellón norteamericano.
O al menos en el estado 51, porque la bandera
parece que ya no cambiará más. Ya veremos
qué impacto tienen entre los puertorriqueños
si el legislativo les vuelve a cerrar las
puertas.
De momento turno para ti:
¿Crees que Puerto Rico tiene que convertirse
en un nuevo estado? ¿Qué beneficios tendría
esta opción? ¿Qué te parece la figura del
estado libre asociado?
Dejanos por aquí tus comentarios y si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
y también a Not News. Podéis hacerlo en
Not News.com
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.